THAT'S SOMETHING I DON'T KNOW.
BUT WE WILL FIND OUT WHEN HE
TESTIFIES.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
I HAVE TO ASK YOU ABOUT THIS,
JEFFREY.
FORMER TRUMP SENIOR AID STEVE
BANNON, AS YOU MIGHT EXPECT, IS
SLAMMING THE HEARINGS AND USING
SOME INCREDIBLY IRRESPONSIBLE
LANGUAGE.
LET'S LISTEN.
>> TRUMP WON THE PRESIDENCY AND
HE'S THE LEGITIMATE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES, AND YOUR GUY
IS ILLEGITIMATE AND YOUR PEOPLE
ARE AWAKING TO THAT.
I DARE MERRICK GARLAND TO TAKE
THAT CRAP LAST NIGHT AND TRY TO
INDICT DONALD J. TRUMP.
WE DARE YOU.
WE'RE GOING TO WIN IN NOVEMBER
AND WE'LL IMPEACH YOU AND
EVERYTHING AROUND YOU.
>> WE KNOW SOMETHING IS
DEFINITELY WRONG WITH STEVE
BANNON BUT ISN'T THERE SOMETHING
WRONG WITH BANNON BEING UNDER
FEDERAL INDICTMENT FOR CONTEMPT
OF CONGRESS AND YET THREATENING
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL OF THIS
COUNTRY?
>> YOU KNOW, I THINK BACK TO THE
FAMOUS COMMENT FROM THE LATE
GREAT SENATOR MOYNIHAN, EVERYONE
IS ENTITLED TO THEIR OWN OPINION
BUT THEY'RE NOT ENTITLED TO
THEIR OWN FACTS.
IT'S NOT A MATTER OF OPINION
WHETHER JOE BIDEN OR DONALD
TRUMP WON THIS ELECTION.
JOE BIDEN WON THIS ELECTION.
THERE IS NO -- NOT EVEN AN
UNSERIOUS DEBATE ABOUT THAT.
AND THE FACT THAT STEVE BANNON
IS STILL USING HIS MICROPHONE,
AS IS DONALD TRUMP, TO CLAIM
OTHERWISE, YOU KNOW, IT JUST
PRESENTS A PROBLEM FOR US AS
JOURNALISTS, I THINK.
WHAT DO WE DO WITH THAT?
YOU KNOW, WE CAN SAY IT'S A LI